I I really believe that there should be
12 step programs for social media and I
am absolutely serious because most of
the people that I met on my journey
spend six to ten hours a day on Facebook
we spend so much time on social media
more time than we do with each other and
I think I think for a lot of people it's
an addiction it's a distraction we use
it to fill a void like we would any
other you know substance um I think it's
one thing if you use social media to
network and say hello maybe post some
fun pictures every now and then but if
you're using it to fill loneliness to
distract yourself from pain then it's
just like a drug it's the same thing as
a drug what do you think about us using
social media as a way to conquer
loneliness but still if we're having
trouble with being intimate with other
people which it's a scary thing to you
know
or if we have social anxiety but then
we're able to connect through online do
you think we're losing I mean that that
I don't know maybe I'm not sure I'm gone
no I know where you're going with it and
and the thing is is that are you truly
connecting with someone through a
machine like is that real connection I I
don't know if it is because sure it's a
connection in a way of maybe filling a
small void of loneliness maybe it's you
know filling a small void of loneliness
but you know Facebook can't hug you it
can't look you in the eyes and say you
know you're not alone or I understand
what you're going through or it's you
know like my cousin got married and sent
me a text to tell me it's like we're not
even we're not even face-to-face to
share in beauty or in pain it's like
it's now in a picture and a status
update and I think that it's I think
it's ultimately going to hurt us as a
society I think it's going to disconnect
us more and more we think it's bringing
us together but actually it's not I mean
especially the younger generation I mean
look at the kids I used to play on my
bike and in the river when I was a kid
and now it's like xbox and wii and
tweeting and facebooking I mean it's out
of hand with the younger generation I've
wondered that too do you think will
repel as a society in 10 years you know
we look back like Oh music videos on MTV
and oh how nostalgic that loo looks now
in the future 10 20 years do you think
there will be a point where we'll just
all unplug in terms of mm-hmm social
media that it's caused things in lives
that yeah I think there's going to be a
huge backlash with social media in like
15 to 20 years I think it's going to be
like you know it used to be fine to
smoke you know in the 30s or whatever
before all the health things came out
about how bad it was for you I mean
they're linking too much Facebook too
much Twitter too much computer used to
anxiety depression autism I mean it's
it's it's pretty crazy and I think that
what's going to happen is is that people
are going to realize that it doesn't
fill that need that we have that
Universal need of love and companionship
and our social skills are diminishing
our kids can't even really functionally
talk to each other I mean it's done so
much through texting I mean you know
kids sending 22,000 texts a month I mean
I'm lucky if I can get out one you know
I'm like but I think there's going to be
a huge backlash and I pray for that I
pray that people will start to unplug
more and and or even just balance it out
instead of you know checking your
Twitter like 70 times a day maybe just
like three times a day because there are
people that will just constantly refresh
over and over and over again and they
just sit there and it breaks my heart
because I know they're lonely you can't
and and all they want is more followers
or more fans Oh follow me and you'll get
more followers but does that what does
that make you feel popular something
does it make you feel more fulfilled
like you're a better person because
that's not what's gonna do it in the
long run don't believe it has facebook
approach to you or
you approached facebook about somehow
releasing the film I haven't talked to
Facebook about it i I just I had
actually the the original title was face
to face book but then they weren't happy
about that so I changed it to face to
face and I you know I don't know how
supportive social media is going to be
because i'm kind of a pioneer for less
social media but i'm not saying no
social media because it's great but i'm
kind of the pioneer of saying less time
on social media more time face-to-face
so you know they want more people on
there so they can still advertise it and
they can make money so when it comes to
money sometimes the little people you
know got to be careful
you